anyway guys enough with the corporate
stuff let's get down to true news all
right we're all here for a good time
thanks for using us us me I could
comment it at the fight whatever yeah
there you see in the petition no I'll
put the link in the description but the
thing that next you guys yeah I saw the
headlines in all the newspapers chubby
funster true Jordy turns up to host the
press conference
motormouth true Jordy I've got a new
Instagram by the way a true Geordie
official but it's spelt ellos ed CAS
inaudible years old
it isn't that he's got 778 just over sin
oh yeah I'd love a 30 so if we could
swallow because there's no way this
chump could have more followers than me
can we sort that oh yeah thank you off
we go guys
see ya get this loose and more followers
[Music]
London how you doing I just want to know
where you're out supporting tonight who
support Logan Paul Eddie hands are
supporting a five year olds birthday
party who's supporting Logan pole then
everyone I'm gonna make some balloons
turn into animals I've got to be on his
ease loving the guy when you met him but
me who's [__] tall honey yeah yeah
Eddie home is tall as [__] yeah six five
what about Jake poo in a place I thought
you guys were - shut up now since I beat
daddy's ass y'all are still bad huh I
didn't actually yeah I didn't hear that
either yeah you couldn't hear a lot this
is all gonna be kinda new to me because
even on stage people are screaming so
loud you can't hear a [__] thing like
half of the answers I was I just looking
at there let's go and when he finishes
I'm just gonna ask another question and
the whole buddy answered it well I don't
you could tell the owner is not a
youtuber but that's why it's so perfect
exactly to introduce the fighter no need
for me we're going to bring up a special
guest to do that ladies and gentlemen a
big London round of applause for true
Jordan
look dude what the [__] is on they told
me not to swear
sorry sky but this is how I run things
the sky guy decide just going I didn't
work with working-class people yeah oh
no they say a lot of funny words I'd had
a lot to drink by the time I got on
stage fact say Brian had enabled himself
quite a lot of women out there below you
kept pouring yeah and there's nothing to
brag about Brian and a drinking problem
isn't something fun it wasn't a solve
problem you know clearly I pissed this
yeah quite literally they did actually
drug test him afterwards the crowd were
[__] loud yeah Soula
and I'd like to say they'd get quite a
loud cheer so thank you to everyone who
was giving me that love yeah there was
one guy who tweeted out his reaction he
was watching during the live show and
you don't like because you never
actually see fans of you reacting to
what you do yeah I love this kid
his name is the gamer reaction yeah my
guy yes yes way
yeah it's like some sort of Charizard in
a pack and he's like yes you got true
Georgie he's wearing glasses you're
wearing glasses you throw yours away why
didn't his away he was cool I do have
fun yeah exactly
oh someone does like me fantastic yeah
coming to the stage
logan paul after seeing levin backstage
i justcouldn't other thing while he is
like a lot bigger than JJ oh yeah and
obviously they would by the time they
weigh in for the fight that size
difference won't be as dramatic but it
just [__] shocked us you sat down
afterwards in the dressing room just
when he looks he doesn't show me as
people yeah I've seen the day I was
right yeah guys been working out some
credit sky and that the production I
can't really complain
other than me not being able to hear
myself for the [__] funds because
I've done this a few times now I just
felt so [__] calm there was no nerves
that was I mean half the bottle of
whiskey might help that but there was
nothing I was just like I'm Lynn control
here the mistakes I've made in the past
or the
you know all the experience has just put
us in that position that we are I could
do this everywhere Eddie was loving it
as well wasn't that's what I liked about
it it was all right okay so what I liked
was that Eddie was quite supportive of
you so afterwards obviously he said I'd
love to he did it he did it like I
couldn't do it and Eddie you got in but
it was also like he was at the back of
it like yeah I've made the right
decision guy like it feels like a
project that I've watched grow so being
a part of it just a little bit as nice
he comes guest as a Frenchman that tush
weirdly like he kind of suits it yeah
yeah she looks great right he looks a
little bit like the bad guy from lovely
bone like I think he looks like a bad
guy generally that's what I thought was
a good thing for him
[Applause]
well yeah probably but use that can't
use it but it was a good little entrance
music came out with a puppy is a lovely
gesture for him to bring out a little
dog and just sort of bring in the
younger audience it's supposed to
represent Logan's dead dog that was
eaten by a coyote
luckily they told me because I thought
if they erupt and this is a you know I
mean yeah otherwise you would have had
told some people bad
Logan would have kicked the dog and I
thought it would go under Logan skin but
it didn't actually affect it well now it
seems as a leak in care sized camp
because let me show you these folks
these are the dog treats that Logan Paul
bought for the dog someone told who's
the snitch Eddie snitches get stitches
I'm just saying if you guys want a
religion shot was Takashi six I imagine
he's in court going and JJ's gonna take
a dog up onstage with him and everyone's
like what okay I want to try one but no
milk can we watch the [__] prosper
okay we get the dog off the stage I was
relieved on the dog off because I was
like how can I [__] ask questions at
this spot this is mad yeah it was really
unusual I didn't really [__] there is no
just weird this was gonna be they say
don't with the children are animals no
yeah that was thing yeah because what
you don't want is a dog [__]
everywhere yeah I did see the dog when
it came offstage the dog was fine the
owner was at the side she was more than
happy I was right there case I was
lovely he was like ah thank you very
much his hands it off-- no dogs were
hurt in the making of this Prescott no
they kicked the whipping is they kick
the dog around backstage afterwards but
during that was like this yeah
absolutely yeah a vote yeah cheering
let's go chop right yo let's [__] that
whole line up let's go Trump let's go
let's go yeah Trump 2020 guys come on
Donald Trump ocean home finally a
support finally a black guy who likes me
[Applause]
wow that's really good reply I only need
three words difficult when told during
dinner but you know
let's go champ paint yes I let this go
for a bit but I was a little bit
concerned at the way Logan was I
posturing me I was like is this guy
gonna make a dot for I like you know I
mean I might I might kill this man I
might kill this man y'all may not know
but JJ's on his abortion his fin that's
five baby's dead and I think i'ma return
the favor and I might kill you man
good lighting to be fair as much as it
probably isn't true or whatever I like
the way JJ sort of reacted to that when
you're on stage I felt like it landed
same question to Logan what did you find
out about JJ in that last fight man's a
dog I'll give you that I didn't realize
I actually did way better than all of
the last press like this what you've
really gotta zoom in on here Eddie just
going oh wow look at these guys
you need the respect of these two lads
to actually just keep it them from not
just screaming at each other what's
really weird about it is they don't well
they clearly respect Eddie but they
didn't show any of that respect in the
last press conference
Eddie sitting there with all these
balloon animals in his pocket going
[__] out to think I was doing a
five-year-old's birthday party last time
this guy question for chair chair coming
into this fight what is your biggest
strength Gordon against Logan my biggest
strength is my actual strength that's
brilliant
my biggest strength is my actual
strength and the strengths you put
strength through further he's making
logical sense I know you mean right in
the stomach if you literally went
literally in my ear I can hear you
saying yo no not now not like this not
like this that's a good line but I heard
that on stage I was like oh that is a
good line same question for Logan what
is your biggest strength coming into
this fight I know how to box now
surprise
turns out I'm pretty [__] good when
he give me more than three months that's
really good
that is it that was good yeah well he's
had so much more time I believed I don't
not you must have improved so much
that's funny I'm expecting Logan to be
way better in this fight but he's also
saying is I didn't really know how to
box well yeah because he only had a
matter of two three months or ever
before the last one now he's had over a
year so when I'm looking at him now I'm
thinking I believe everything you say
then whoever's gonna win is we're still
yet to really break that down but I
believe what he's saying there when he
says he knows how to box and he's coming
in a much better boxer just seeing this
image here is like before and after I'm
one of those subway cars and great the
situation down for me like this is the
biggest guy closest to these two people
are you thinking I could break this up
at this point I'm thinking the man was
the most first-round knockouts in
Heavyweight history is on my left and
Videl Riley who's probably going to be a
cruiserweight champ you know the world
is on my right and they're throwing
things at each other yeah and if it does
break out into a fight I'm pretty sure
I'm [__]
yeah not only that but for some reason
Leon and Vidal both look relatively
fearless in this scenario that we like
children Leon's literally throwing
t-shirts at a man who his only job for
years actually shunran's actually making
like some good points in terms of trying
to question Vidal's credibility
obviously in reality we know avatars
like a British Amateur champion it's
been boxing since he was [__] two
months old or young so he doesn't know
that so that's his way of like or not
well you've only had three fights you're
the other it does some worse coming from
a guy who has been a heavyweight world
champion it's a good job it's a good
statement Jerry to try and prove a point
I think Logan's team where they are in
this then in any press conference they
Danya basically the British humor is
just overwhelmed them in the past they
did Al and JJ are so good at taking the
piss but I think they brought their
a-game than this one and can I just say
I look good there look at that look at
them mmm whoever wins this fight Logan
Oh JJ you know their coach is going to
storm the ring and be like really
gloating any other ones face yeah
absolutely loving this rivalry now
between Shannon and Reid olive oil is
making the fight even more fun by the
way you just silenced previous
heavyweight world champion by going all
right all right yeah girlfriends I don't
mean to be a prick yeah and he's
literally looking at you going [__]
allied suck his dick right now you've
made since the last fight question Jordy
there's one change really comic I will
use my mic now no but that's really good
like he is just a showman yeah yeah that
was very funny I'm gonna win wow that
was hard that was hard work for me at
that point so he didn't really answer
that question like what changes you made
so I basically was like I'm gonna follow
this up and actually force you answer
this yes mom you were able to land the
job early on in the last fight but you
couldn't make it counted enough what is
what are those differences how are you
gonna make that count this time I didn't
know what I was doing last year now I
know what I'm doing with fish bro I mean
at the face yeah this is the best press
conference that these two have done
along yeah it was the one that bordered
on like a regular boxing press
conference as well as these two being
the entertainers they are a little funny
moments where he said I'm gonna slap you
with a fish yeah just like I wanna punch
you in the face hey you won't get
oh you big chick stands up straight away
lovin it Oh Eddie's right let's just
let's just keep this [__] good I love
it at this point he's like you want to
do the balloon animals show credits the
security they were out there in like a
snap this security did well yeah really
good the guys that bought for these lot
nor where are they from
because I've met Eddie Hall he was the
World's Strongest Man
I wasn't that much smaller than him I
was like now you're the world's
strongest man I'm not that much smaller
these guys I mean this guy is really
tall but I'm talking about some of the
other guys in the back are you even not
[__] humor we the same he sees these
dinosaurs yeah yeah David Icke might
have a point about this reptilian thing
but yeah it's just not look in the right
place it's not looking at the royal
family look at the security any security
or bodyguards on it if you could that'd
be fantastic this is the moment I was I
I'm gonna [__] put the pressure on
Jake a little bit and get an answer out
of him your boy George is an interviewer
this is what you've got to do isn't it
you got to probably put these questions
to them get bored sees that you're
scared to fight him will you fight
Dibble 110 percent this man is 5/8 got
tired at five minutes in his last fight
this is a joke that means Jake's been
looking at the footage though he's been
studying them he's been really
considering this look at the footage
that I haven't seen yeah I think that
fight was gonna happen I hope so getting
a little bit out of control gotta bring
a butt now yeah yeah you and Eddie
Eddie's going bring it back now Brian
bring it back I don't have to get the
balloon animals out I just said Logan
can you sit your [__] brother doumitt
appreciate that because you kind of need
the team's to help me yeah I did really
well to pull that back from where it was
a [__] I'm not give I'm not digging
myself a little bit big myself because
if this had happened last year when gear
board come on stage
that's where the whole press conference
would have probably ended yeah it would
have just gotten out of control
AB see it's gonna be naughty bro no
it'll be bad I'm gonna give up a wet
willy through your bellybutton
I know it's such a weird way also
because your own boxing gloves it's
impossible you got no fans coming into
this fight yeah I feel much different
that's a great question here's the
difference
I have a mustache now as weird as Logan
is I feel like this confidence is
winning him this exchange this was
almost a character that he's embodied
and just come out and staging on I'm
just gonna say whatever the hell I want
I don't I've taken this seriously I love
it but the fact that he kind of just
some names that he answered questions
but he wasn't really answering he was
just going off in that diary - now I did
really announcer it worked actually
really well for him yeah it's so weird
but so [__] funny also unusual
because he picked out the right camera
oh break down the left yeah then it was
faceoff time what were your thoughts
during the faceoff if there'd be anyone
who was noticeably like rattled because
going about like JJ vs. Joe Walla for
example you could sort of feel that JJ
was so much more confident I just wanted
to see if there was a clear person who's
the most confident out of the two when
they faced off JJ instantly grew in my
example no way and I was like oh and he
just started talking [__] and then log
and didn't speak as much it was like the
rules that reversed in a flash just
casually chatting me that here and there
now that's you just they're just going
wanna go for a drink after they say yeah
I was actually saying you owe me a break
yeah okay the longer they stand there
the more likely it becomes that
someone's gonna do something
[Music]
that was kind of cool what he did there
both of them are quite cool I think
Logan knew it had gone better for him
than the previous one side huh huh I
don't think JJ had a bad performance I
just think Logan did better than he's
done previously so Logan will be buoyed
by that yeah how do you think agent I
think this is like a great confidence
booster for Logan
whereas JJ just need to remain calm use
a home the crowd did most of his
challenge yeah I felt like the JJ
definitely won the first press
conference and I'd say Logan edged this
press conference confidence was was on a
10 yeah you'd say JJ was maybe a 9 sure
it wasn't like a much difference but I
just felt like Logan edged a 9.5 yeah
moving on unboxing news Suzy had a what
do we call it
boxing much I don't think it was that in
the end I think fousey if he knew
anything about boxing would be actually
really good no I know that might sound
mad he's got heart he's a pretty strong
guy you know he's pretty athletic I
don't feel like he's been taught how
about but then I've got it under good
authority that his coaches are actually
decent I just don't understand what
happened here but let's face the
commentary sounds like that's done on a
walkie-talkie yeah man if the whole of
true news was just us in between
perfectly audio clips just going wrong
unwatchable Suzy has got actual power
like he's a big strong kid just doesn't
know how to use it at all so you went
out there
Luers lured in about 20 seconds and it
was all we've all done it we've all been
there yeah figuratively are literally
just have to be ready for round 2 which
I'm not sure Suzy was to give us half an
hour doesn't work yeah when the referee
came over he went seriously darling I
can't go again and he was like no Matt
you've got to you literally have to you
will be disqualified exactly yeah
a lot of girlfriends I hear do say that
to their boyfriends
[Music]
he's actually doing the cheat code for
GTA 2009 left right left right triangle
all he had to do to win this fight
realistic because to slim this guy is no
disrespect one but he's not great either
he just had to cut the ring off and
smoke him one in the [__] bear
breadbasket and then go up top and he
would have B would have won this fight
quite easily remember resident evil
mm-hmm and like 28 days later yeah
zombies yeah cause he just reminds me
like Oh covered for you under there yeah
with a cold I actually had my other guys
hot like he take not many punches in the
head yeah and keep coming forward
fearfully this ROM said if he knew
anything you'd be great yeah
[Applause]
people in Yemen who this is the charity
for we're watching this and gunk those
poor people I was not the worst fight
I've ever yeah do you think probably the
worst fight I've ever seen in terms of
quality of fight it's right I know he's
still worse fighter fair enough fair
enough
however creditor Fuzzy's got hot that's
the type of heart you've got to have in
determination when you try and convince
the world like Drake's coming to your
party yeah no wonder he went with ya cuz
to him he's like I'll take risks if
Drake doesn't show up is fighting I got
punched in the face whatever made all
that's how he lives his life like yeah
risks to phousi are just another day
who's the type of guy who just do like a
parachute German to play in it and just
use a backpack yeah I'm sure you
actually need a parachute in the
buck-buck say say a minute what's them
what's in the backpack I've got my
bedsheets you know yeah I've probably
got my bed sheet I'll be fine yeah that
looks like a pillowcase phousi same
thing so UFC fighter and former podcast
guest of true Geordie Michael Bisping
has revealed that he'd been fighting for
a lot of his career we don't know how
long but we know not long ago you want a
[__] UFC title with one eye he got
his head kicked by a juiced-up Vitor
Belfort and had an injured eye for a
long time there was this big deal made
about how bad the I was secretly
fighting with one eye because the UFC
wouldn't have allowed him to fight if
they'd known that and what that means is
his depth perception judging punches all
of that would have been a massively
affected but this man was sawed-off he
won the middleweight title with one
[__] eye and he's proving it on his
podcast amazing less watch
Wow the man gave an eye up to the sport
that is so uncomfortable I feel because
I like to love this firelight I've
watched him what like four years and I
was like oh you poor bastard like you
you fought that many killers that you
ended up losing a [__] eye losing an
eye is one thing but losing an eye to
someone that you know has done something
to get ahead in a game that can put a
lot of men under almost because they
think why is the world been so harsh on
me why have I heard this injustice
instead of letting it get him down
this guy has literally come back and use
that as a fuel well we are weirdly Vitor
Belfort was sort of a victim of getting
in the UFC as well because his his
sister was kidnapped they never got her
back and she disappeared basically so
like when you become a cage fighter like
it's just a lot to consider
this is sitting kind of closing holes
talking about China in the UFC yeah
maybe just yeah we don't want to see
Jake kidnapped yeah especially not as I
imagine the kidnappers ultimately would
be like we can't take it anymore having
back Tyson Fury has been in the WWE
recently squaring off against this rest
are called braun strowman it's a real
name that isn't Israeli they definitely
thought of that for a while because it
is sort of character twenty years ago
they had Stone Cold Steve Austin and I
in my tyson facing off and they trying
to sort of recreate that with these two
and honestly it's just not as good
that's cuz it was Iron Mike Tyson a man
who you couldn't really what he was
gonna say he'd literally just got out of
prison
yeah so he was like the world's most
feared man at that point and Tyson Fury
is actually kind of like a really good
guy now comedic yeah they've been doing
stuff in the ring we can't show cuz WEA
just copyright strike everything but I'm
worried because he didn't look great in
his last fight fury he looked good
enough to win but not the best fury
yeah and then he's pissing around in the
W E and I got it it's part of building
his profile in America leave this for
after your career exactly don't do a
Conor McGregor I remember mayweather did
this at one point where W anything you
know it was like point he was sort of
retired and he was just gushing in or
simply who's he
find Rey Mysterio yeah I mean you
punched the big short was ridiculous so
yeah I'm a bit like I just want to see
him training hard and being the best but
I'd love to get Tyson on the podcast if
he wants to build this profile maybe
someone could reach out all right that's
the end of true news this week don't do
Pierce I Logan Paul Eddie Hearn all the
lads for having me on the press
conference really enjoyed it mMmmm we
did give you that bow tie I mean fourth
time's the charm or something like that
yeah we'll say that with the commentary
as well don't forget you were follow me
new Instagram true jolly official and
also like and subscribe and if you want
you follow Lawrence as well whatever
means yes main yeah so yeah he's gone
he's gone